[Music]
many factors combine to create
serious visual problems for the pilot of
today's high performance aircraft
complicated instrument panels
the structure of the aircraft
congestion and takeoff and landing areas
accelerations
high altitudes
high speeds the most important and
critical of these factors is speed
speeds greater than the speed of sound
up to 1 000 knots are not uncommon now
in the foreseeable future speeds up to
2000 knots will be everyday occurrences
even at today's speeds a routine
situation
such as citing an object a mile away
could turn into a disaster before the
pilot could do anything about it
the instant an object enters the pilot's
field of view
he must see it identify it and perform
the proper action
however each of the tasks requires time
usually a very short interval but an
interval that may
well mean hundreds or thousands of feet
travel in a high-speed aircraft
as speeds increase the situation can
become even worse
this film will demonstrate some of the
specific visual problems the aviator
will encounter at the very high speeds
of today's and tomorrow's aircraft
we first review some physical conditions
that exist at high speeds and high
altitudes
and their possible effects on visual
performance
when the aircraft travels at subsonic
speeds
air particles are able to get out of its
way as the aircraft approaches the speed
of sound
the air in front of it is compressed
into a wave front which is not very
dense
and reaches far ahead of the aircraft as
the speed increases
the air in the wavefront becomes more
dense more compressed
until at transonic speeds the aircraft
faces what amounts to an increasingly
solid wall of air
the aircraft cannot pierce this
wavefront and is never able to get ahead
of it
the flow of air in the wavefront is not
absolutely consistent and alike
throughout the way
and therefore produces mild rippling
effects such as can be seen in heat
waves
the build up in pressure results in the
formation of shock waves
in the transonic range of speeds the
buffeting of the aircraft
results from alternate collapse and
re-establishment of flow due to an
unstable shockwave formation
it's been reported that the buffeting
may cause a momentary blurring of the
pilot's vision
when the aircraft passes through this
speed range of mixed airflows
it has passed through the sonic barrier
at supersonic speeds the shock waves
become more stable
and form an increasingly acute angle as
speed increases
the air in shock waves is optically more
dense than normal air
this density produces a deviation of
light rays which apparently causes a
displacement of objects from their true
positions
however this displacement is slight
there has been much discussion about
vibration of jet aircraft and
rocket-propelled aircraft in the
supersonic speed range
however no vibrations of intensities
great enough to harm
human eyes or seriously interfere with
visual performance have been reported
acceleration does not seriously
interfere with the vision of an
aviator who is wearing either a full
pressure suit or a good g
suit however without such protection an
acceleration of six g's will cause
practically any aviator who is in an
upright position to black out
naturally this effect is limiting on
high-speed flight
we now examine some of the factors that
relate to the pilot's recognition of
objects in the air
these factors are greatly affected by
high speeds and high altitudes
the size of the target is extremely
important in relation to whether it can
be
seen if the target moves away its size
decreases
if the overall illumination and contrast
between the target and its background
remain constant
there is a size below which the target
cannot be seen
we will use this triangle to demonstrate
size
under optimum conditions of illumination
in order to see and identify an object
five miles away
the object must be thirty feet in
diameter
some modern aircraft are less than the
size when measured from a head-on
profile
as distance decreases the target size
increases until it reaches the size at
which it can be seen
another characteristic related to
recognition is the size of the visual
field in which the target must fall in
order to be seen
in studying this problem we will use
this drawing of the human eye
seen in cross section at maximum
distance
the target must fall on the exact center
of the retina
the area of best visual acuity in order
for the pilot to see it
this means the target must appear in a
small cone
less than one degree in cross-section
with the cone reaching the fovea
the exact center of the retina a target
twice the size required for central
vision can be recognized in a 10 degree
cone
a target four times the size required
for central vision
can be recognized anywhere in a 26
degree cone
the size of the cone in which a target
can be recognized
is also important because of the expanse
of sky a pilot must search
to detect or see a target a pilot has no
accurate way of knowing whether his
scanning pattern is fine enough
whether he is covering all areas of the
sky in which he can detect and recognize
the target
for example if this aircraft can be seen
only by foveal vision
this scan will miss it entirely
in addition at high altitudes the sky is
generally empty of any visual references
or cues that can serve as guides for a
systematic scanning pattern
if a target is seen and the eyes are
momentarily shifted away from it
there is difficulty in relocating it
because there are no visual cues
the boundaries and structure of the
windscreen do however provide a little
help as a visual reference
but when the pilot knows a target is
nearby
he often does not see it for example
at high altitudes and high speeds pilots
who are trying to rendezvous at a
pre-arranged position
have difficulty locating each other
pilots have chased other aircraft for
more than a hundred miles
knowing from their electronic gear that
they were always as near as five miles
and sometimes less than one mile away
and yet
were never able to sight the other
aircraft visually
these failures were not due to
navigational errors
but to a fundamental visual cause above
forty thousand feet
ninety percent of visual sightings made
by pilots
are by means of glints of light flashes
from the other aircraft
these glints occur only when the other
aircraft maneuvers so that reflections
from its surface happen to be toward the
direction of the pilot
in other words at high altitudes and
high speeds
if the other aircraft does not glint it
probably will not be seen
another reason for failure to see other
aircraft at high altitudes
is that the pilot having nothing distant
to look at
unconsciously keeps his eyes in focus
for objects nearby
for practical purposes he is blind to
objects in space
he may even fail to see other aircraft
that are not far away
to avoid this he should try to focus his
eyes at least 20 feet away which is the
same as for infinity
in recognition and closure at high
speeds the most limiting factor with
which the pilot must contend
is his own lag and visual perception and
the time he requires to react to the
sight of the object
specifically this is the time it takes a
pilot to see
identify and act the instant an object
enters his field of vision and
immediately thereafter
there are certain physiological tasks to
be performed
by the pilot's eyes brain and muscles
each of these tasks take some time in
some instances it takes
only a very short interval but an
interval in which a high-speed aircraft
may travel hundreds or even thousands of
feet
we will examine a routine problem a
pilot
represented by this eye is flying at 600
knots
when an object enters his peripheral
vision that is just at the corner of his
eye
before showing the problem in motion we
will use this 10 second stopwatch
and we'll analyze what is to happen in
terms of time
it will take one tenth of a second for
the sensation of the object to reach the
brain
about three-tenths of a second will pass
while the brain
signals the eye to move and the lens
focuses the object on the phobia
nearly seven tenths of a second will
pass before the brain recognizes the
object as an aircraft
two seconds will pass while the brain
decides what to do
and signals the muscles nearly two and a
half seconds will pass while the muscles
operate the controls and the aircraft
changes its flight path
this is a total of about five and a half
seconds
not a long time under normal
circumstances
but look at it again now in slow motion
with this object motionless and this
aircraft moving at 600 knots
the pilot will travel a hundred feet
before he even sees the object
he will travel nearly 400 feet before
his phobia picks up the object
he will travel over a thousand feet
before he recognizes the object as an
aircraft
he will travel a half mile before he can
decide what to do
and he will travel over four-fifths of a
mile
before his flight path changes
but of course both aircraft will be
moving at 600 knots
two pilots on opposite courses would
have to see each other at a distance of
11 000 feet
in order to change their flight pads in
time to avoid collision
at eighteen hundred knots these
distances will be trebled
the pilot will travel over a mile and a
half before he can decide what to do
and he will travel over two and a half
miles before he can alter his flight
path
imagine two aircraft heading for each
other at speeds of 1800 knots
if they emerge from cloud cover 600 feet
apart
neither pilot will see the other
aircraft before they collide
they emerge three miles apart they will
collide before the pilots can decide
what to do
and if they emerge five miles apart they
are still
too close to change their flight pads
some of the time intervals used in this
discussion are not subject to very
careful and accurate measurement
however if they are wrong it is probably
on the side of being too short
except for the response time of the
aircraft itself these time intervals are
due solely to the unchanging and
unalterable characteristics of the
normal human eye
brain and muscles the time intervals for
recognition and action
are based on conditions that are ideal
for example a clear day
an alert experienced pilot with no
distractions
and where only the simplest of tasks are
involved
these time intervals and distances could
increase by several seconds and
thousands of feet
due to any number of complications that
could occur in perfectly normal flight
for example anything that interfered
with the pilot's vision
such as a structural member of the
aircraft
haze or gray out induced by high
acceleration
any of these things could add to the
time the pilot requires to see
and recognize an object in the sky
additional problems of time and distance
arise when a pilot performs a relatively
quick and simple task
such as glancing down at a flight
instrument by the time he adjusts his
eyes to focus on the instrument
reads it then shifts his eyes to the sky
again
he will have traveled thousands of feet
while flying blind
this can have serious consequences for
example the pilot traveling at several
hundred knots
glances at his altimeter another
aircraft coming out of the clouds a mile
away
will be on top of him before he even
knows it's there
the reason is simple to look at the
instrument and readjust the eyes to the
interior illumination
takes about eight tenths of a second to
recognize the instrument reading
takes another eight tenths of a second
to look up and readjust to the outside
distant focus
takes another eight tenths of a second a
total of nearly two and a half seconds
during this time an aircraft at 600
knots
will travel 2400 feet while at 1800
knots it will travel about 7 200 feet
well over a mile
the time interval could be greatly
increased where the pilot looks from a
bright sky to a dimly lit panel
he must adapt to the dim light then he
must readjust to the brightness outside
even the short time consumed in reading
instruments
in seeing and identifying objects and in
reacting properly can be vital
in avoiding collisions and intercepting
other aircraft
nearly three-quarters of recent mid-air
collisions occurred in straight and
level flight
nearly all were attributed to failure of
a pilot to see the other aircraft in
time
in some cases the pilot never saw the
other aircraft at all
when the other aircraft was seen the
distance and rate of closure probably
were misjudged
or both pilots in attempting to turn
away turned into each other
many near-misses have been reported the
majority occurred on route during full
daylight with visibility to 15 miles or
more
near misses of today may be collisions
tomorrow when more
aircraft are traveling and at greater
speeds
to avoid a collision it is important
only that the other aircraft be seen in
time to keep from hitting it
this includes seeing it well enough to
establish its course
where the basic problem is preventing
collisions aircraft can be designed to
be as conspicuous as possible
this includes the use of paints and
markings as well as conspicuous lights
interception involves approaching other
aircraft deliberately
while avoiding collisions with them
interception includes rendezvousing with
friendly aircraft
it also includes identifying unreported
aircraft
and it includes attacking enemy aircraft
most of the time electronic equipment
both airborne and on the ground
helps a pilot to perform a mission of
interception however a pilot usually
must
actually see the aircraft he is
intercepting
as early as possible
he must see it at a great distance so he
can identify it positively
this frequently means identifying an
aircraft that is painted so as to be as
inconspicuous as possible
the recognition time here would probably
stretch out to at least one and a half
seconds
1520 feet at 600 knots
the distance must also be great enough
for the pilot to maneuver into an
attacking position
if that becomes necessary
high speed is the single most important
factor related to recognition and
closure
and speeds will be even greater in the
future this makes it all the more
important to make every allowance for
the pilot's lag in perception and
reaction time the time intervals
required to see
and react cannot be reduced because they
are due to
the unchanging characteristics of the
normal human
eye mind and muscles pilot errors that
have resulted in most collisions relate
directly
to the eye mind and muscles
they are failure to see the other
aircraft
misjudgment of distance and failure to
take the proper
corrective action in time thus
prevention of collisions
depends on in-flight recognition of
another aircraft
and an awareness of the problems of
closure rates of speed
there are three main areas of exposure
to mid-air collisions
areas around congested terminals and
airfields
during maneuvers especially climbing and
turning
under cruise conditions where the pilot
may tend to relax and be less alert
in other words to goof off
there are several things that you the
pilot can do to prevent or avoid
mid-air collisions and perform your
missions of interception efficiently
don't fly unless you are in good
condition
rest and relax between missions in the
air
watch your electronic gear for any clue
to another aircraft or object
note the direction indicated by the gear
and look in that direction for visual
contact
your object is to see the other aircraft
at the greatest possible distance
look for glints or bright flashes from
the other aircraft
think about your speed and your rate of
closure on the other aircraft
and keep on thinking about it know your
own physical limitations
remember you have to see identify
and react this takes time
keep alert look
keep alive look
remember that today's and tomorrow's
aircraft
are the aircraft of the thinking and
looking man
so think and look stay
alert and then keep on looking
[Music]